und über die aktuelle situation in der
ukraine kann ich jetzt sprechen mit
harald kujat er ist der ehemalige
vorsitzender des nato-militärausschusses
und generale de guten tag herr kujat
also zum zweiten mal sagen jedenfalls
die russen sind sogenannte hyperschall
waffen dort eingesetzt worden in der
ukraine wie ist das aus ihrer sicht zu
bewerten
nun es ist einfach so zu bewerten dass
die
dass die russischen streitkräfte die
intensität der kampfhandlungen steigern
das war zu erwarten und das ist nicht
der letzte steigerung schritt es werden
weitere folgen was haben wir uns
darunter vorzustellen
nun wie es werden weiter weitreichende
waffensysteme eingesetzt waffensysteme
die nicht abgeschossen werden können
dazu fehlen die möglichkeiten
und wir werden aussehen dass die
kampfhandlungen sich intensivieren
werden wenn die russischen streitkräfte
verstärkt in die urbanen gebiete
hineingehen die sie jetzt im augenblick
nur von außen beschießen also in die
größeren städte auch dann gibt es
häuserkämpfe die äußerst verlustreich
sind und zwar für beide seiten eine
diese stadt dieser stätte ist ja mario
pohl wir hören dass mario pohl offenbar
kurz vor dem fall steht was hätte es aus
ihrer sicht strategisch zu bedeuten wenn
diese stadt wirklich in die hände der
russen gerät
hat eine geografisch eine
schlüsselposition in der verbindung zu
zu russland hin und ist insofern
wichtig für russland es ist auch viel
symbolkraft er ein wichtiges ziel für
russland was würden sie jetzt glauben
sie würden die russen weiter vorgehen
man hat ja den eindruck das ist offenbar
ja vor allem auch rundum kiew einen
regelrechten stellungskrieg zu geben
scheint glauben sie dass die russen
versuchen noch weiter ins landesinnere
zu gehen oder werden dir vor allem die
großen städte wie sie sagten versuchen
aus zu bomben- und auszuhungern
naja ich habe keine glaskugel in der ich
sozusagen in die russischen planungen
hin anschauen kann wie das einige
unserer experten tun was wir bis jetzt
sehen ist dass russland es vermeidet von
anfang an in die großen städte hinein zu
gehen und zwar deshalb weil die ukraine
dort taktisch im vorteil sind mit ihren
panzerabwehrwaffen und ihren stinger
raketen also auf kurze reichweite die
ukrainische streitkräfte sind eben nicht
in der lage wie das normalerweise wäre
das gefecht der verbundenen waffen zu
führen also die russischen angriff teile
direkt von tal anzugreifen
sie ziehen sich in die städte zurück und
russland versucht dieses risiko so lange
es irgendwie geht zu vermeiden und das
bedeutet dass diese städte eben
beschlossen werden ständig von
russischer artillerie und russischen
luftstreitkräfte und das bedeutet eben
auch verluste bei der zivilbevölkerung
es gibt in der ukraine jedenfalls in der
bevölkerung offenbar die hoffnung dass
es mit dem nato gipfel der in der
nächsten woche stattfinden soll eine
veränderung der nato politik geben
könnte im hinblick auf vielleicht sogar
bodentruppen was denken sie wird die
nato abgehen von ihrer vorgehensweise
oder wird es dabei bleiben an dem was
sie bisher ja von sich gegeben hat und
auch praktiziert hat dass sie sich nicht
in den krieg hineinziehen lassen will
und will das wirklich jemand will ein
westlicher politiker den krieg auf ganz
europa ausdehnen das ist doch hier die
frage will ein westlicher politiker
riskieren dass ein solcher
konventioneller krieg
eskaliert auch hin zu einem nuklearen
krieg ich habe große zweifel dass das
jemand will sei denn er ist nicht mehr
bei verstand und präsident biden hat das
ja nun mehrfach sehr deutlich gemacht es
wird keinen konventionellen krieg geben
zwischen der nato und russland auch
deshalb nicht weil dir das risiko einer
eskalation einen nuklearkrieg zu groß
ist sagt harald kujat der general ade
ich sage danke für die st danke für ihre
zeit an diesem sonntag gerne